good morning everybody excuse us for the
technical problems we are having all the
comments and questions at the young of
the presentations and welcome back to
our first session of this last day of
the pic conference my name is al wadi
ahead i am a postdoctoral fellow the
problem in a writing studies and it's my
pleasure to take part in this conference
and introduce our few panels for the
discussion about human hug labor
ecologist our first speaker sis you're a
huge assistant professor of basser
college mother and every modern self
asha focusing on topics as environmental
history british colonialism and Indian
identity her first book was animal
kingdom's hunting the environment and
power in the Indian princely states who
deals with some Indian princes through
their engagement with animals and the
environments in their state our second
speaker will be Brad Mitchell professor
of history and editor of American
Studies at california state university
long beach and the author of p a book
where she traces an natural and cultural
history of the pig and our third speaker
is mindy is neither an assistant
professor in agrarian food and
environmental studies at the
international institute of social
studies in the egg in the netherlands so
thank you all and less began the
conversation
alright can you hear me well it's just
about the right place excellent alright
okay now one question I found the
keyboard we're good okay all right so
let me just get started we'll dive right
in dotted with man-made lakes irrigated
fields and the rugged semi-arid peaks of
the Aravalli range may wash state was
prime pig country in the eighteenth
nineteenth and early twentieth centuries
the states to Saudi orogeny lose in
their nobles celebrated local bore for
their succulent flesh robust size and
defiant character pig hunting parties
were regular affairs or were driven by
beaters are or baited with popcorn and
sweets chased down on horseback shot
with rifles are tackled on foot with
Qatar's which is a kind of a punching
style of knife at the same time peasants
ranging from sharecroppers and laborers
through the privileged rentier classes
experienced boris agricultural pests and
only occasionally as pork usually is
poached struggling to protect their
livelihoods peasants guarded their crops
and petitioned landlords tax collectors
and their prints while richer peasants
and proprietors fortified their fields
and deflected most of their losses as
much as they could on to their tenants
the full scope of historical
interactions among princes peasants and
pigs in may are cannot be recovered from
the archives alone simply not there but
paintings from the Royal Atelier and
here's when a draft stage can help
illuminate the written records
clarifying what board did and how the
state that is the prince and his Nobles
wanted pigs and their works perceived
with rare exceptions wild boar appear in
paintings only as objects of the hunt
their works however crop up in scenes
that ostensibly have nothing to do with
pig including elephant fights Hawking
expeditions wedding receptions and
ritual observances the influence of
these animals is there to be seen
if only we learn where and how to look
ultimately it is this tension between
the animals invisible presence in
courtly paintings and the ubiquity of
its impact on the environment social and
political landscapes that I'm attempting
to explore in this paper first some
background context you learn a little
bit more about may or what the heck you
were talking about for that a map might
be helpful there we go so in the inset
you've got India of course the portion
that is outlined fairly dark and says
rajputana that's where we're zoomed in 2
and then may war is towards the south of
the state there it's you can see rather
lumpy we thought the Aravalli range
that's my my lovely rivoli range there
that I was talking about the capital
city incidentally is uday port there if
you can see that touted today and this
is on the lineages own website as the
world's oldest serving dynasty with
Constance toad Ian ship unbroken since
730 for ad the ciseaux dia rajput
princess of mayo are and they're 16
chief nobles experienced volatile times
in the 18th century the centralizing
force of the Mughal Empire was
fracturing along with the honors and
protections it offered and the services
and revenues it extracted murata armies
were rating from the south and east
besieging forts and cities and demanding
ransoms the memoirs rulers ultimately
funded by extracting more from their
agricultural base from mid-century the
English east india company to embarked
on an era of aggressive expansion
spreading its territories and influence
from Calcutta in the north Bombay in the
east and Madras in the south reaching
may war and the wider rajputana region
by about the 1800 mark harried by
internal rebellions and external threats
the reigning maharana of May waar that's
the king of noir in 1818 contracted a
Treaty of Perpetual friendship alliance
and unity of interests with the English
company that nevertheless stipulated
subordinate cooperation with the British
government this treaty promise to
maintain the princes absolute sovereign
of his own country it also set a high
yearly tribute to be paid to the company
alienated the right to wage war and
submitted border disputes to British
arbitration also if you wanted to send a
letter to the neighboring Prince you had
to route that through the British
government lots of fun a war in its
neighbours much like much of the
subcontinent had enjoyed a period of
agricultural expansion competitive real
wages and in frequent droughts from the
mid 17th through the early eighteenth
centuries by the mid 1700s however
nearby Eastern rajputana so that's
focused on on the region of Jaipur and
windy just to kind of the northeast and
presumably may war to we don't have
those numbers yet was slipping into
depression in the agrarian economy major
droughts increased from one every six to
ten years between 1655 and 1735 to one
every two and a half years by 1813 and
you're going to continue about that rate
up through around 1900 these trends
continued or combined to push peasants
more into debt many with land or capital
goods sold off their assets some opted
for migration other state port and just
kind of went with it struggled through
it numbers from just northeast of mayo
are are illustrative in one of these
districts before the year 1760 the poor
peasants had 300 plows that you know are
in the tax records after that mark they
have only 50 plows so pretty big dive in
another district in the area before 1753
they had 700 plows by 1764 they were
down to 28 when weather or wildlife
damaged crops losses theoretically were
shared among primary producers and
others including landowners in the state
officials measured fields examined crops
and survey damage before estimating
pre-tax yields assessment rates on these
estimates depended on variables
including a cultivators cast period of
residents in the village if you were a
new arrival you actually got a tax cut
to encourage in migration your proximity
to a hunting reserve could bring it down
the assessment and then of course state
need mattered a great deal
in addition to the state's quarter third
or half share other stakeholders took
their cuts in proportion smaller
estimates of course meant smaller shares
all around and larger larger shares
still operating under a broadly similar
system in the early 20th century
cultivators complained that those in
charge routinely overestimated yields
particularly ignoring damage caused by
wildlife including wild war in the 18th
century to when drought debt and
dispossession were stripping the margins
away the losses caused by wild boar
could be more than a nuisance they could
certainly be a matter of life and death
turning to more of the evidence some of
the pictures everything I've done before
here is it's kind of a recap of existing
literature things were clearly in the
picture as a major concern of the state
and a source of conflict but how did
these dramas play out in 18th century
may wiring miniatures that's my question
here in a painting of maharana sangron
sing let me get that up for you here we
go in this painting and he's raining
he's on the throne from 17 10 to 17 34
the painting is from 1725 here we see
the Prince his nobles and servants four
times in succession as they arrive on
the hunting ground maybe I can do this
we there they are arriving now I lost my
place of course pursue and kill one more
with dogs and Spears so they're starting
the pursuit here there's the pig and
interaction with this noble and he's
actually killed over here then there's a
second war he gets lost well he doesn't
get lost they lose him he starts there
than he appears in this plot of
cultivation hides there for a little
while but then makes a break for it and
as you can see this Archer manages to
get one shot at him as he runs away but
he does it does appear successfully
escapes this is one of the very few may
War II miniatures it actually shows a
pig in the midst of crops and we can
return to that point later according to
Molly Emma aitken she's an art historian
who's worked on these on a war ii
miniatures extensively images such as
these were intended to picture
a feeling and not a scene artist painted
how may worry people places and events
were felt by insiders and not just how
they might have looked to outsiders in
this particular painting neither the
hunting ground or the villages are
recognizable as specific named places
the quite abstract nonetheless the
suitably trained local connoisseur of
the Arts a Rajput rasika good Sanskrit
term there would experience this
fantastically green hilly and prosperous
landscape with its heroic Prince and his
pic sticking entourage as essentially
may worry this also there's going to be
styles in the way the faces are depicted
that will make this look may worry and
not like one of the neighboring states
and their paintings or their landscape
the foreground sets the dominant mood
with scenes literally dripping with
heroic courage or viera rasa I say
dripping because Russa it's it means
juice it means liquid and this is the
term for the essence of the painting
that produces the emotion or the feeling
in the viewer a male and female
blackbuck are hanging out in the back up
here a little hard to see in fact
there's two females and then probably
invisible to you guys but up here there
is a lone village beauty hanging out as
well these stock figures in the
background are also suggesting the savor
of love chingado rasa is also evident in
this painting rain dark clouds and
saturated greenery recalled the monsoon
the season most evocative in India of
romance here the unremitting Green is
not so much a document of reality as a
marker of pava of feeling infused
fertility disseminated by the prints
even as mwari paintings evoked emotion
and from the early 18th century were
also according to Aiken documenting a
web of relationships among king Nobles
subjects and landscapes i would add pigs
as well to that they were documenting
these things in detailed inscriptions on
the back of the paintings nevertheless
the political function was to praise a
thriving kingdom and it's worthy King so
we're getting this interesting mixture
of feeling of
and then idealize idealism this is where
the pig in the unprotected field comes
into focus so our fellow who's on his
way to escape the animal is there in
part because the real pig during the
real hunt really went there but the
artist used the pig to draw attention to
typical may worry crops well ideal would
be in other word to use sending a
message of prosperity reiterated in the
nearby pukka villages pukka is solid it
is is cooked it is finished so buildings
made out of brick made out of solid
material not out of mud not out of
thatch or things like that this is a
marker of a very good marker of being
prosperous the animals intrusion was not
intended to raise questions about
cultivator vulnerability sovereign and
negligence or the rapacity of Assessors
and tax collectors these villages are
well off hedging is within their means
but evidently not worth their while
according to this painting this prints
in fact is not protecting his subjects
from marauding pigs rather he and his
nobles are proving themselves against a
worthy foe while reaffirming their
mutual bonds and hierarchies all against
the backdrop of an idealized a motive
may woori landscape that subtly hints
and more amorous pursuits and those more
amorous pursuits have a very recognised
place in the appropriate and in the
necessary action of Indian Kings if you
get really into the the theory of it a
king who does not engage in amorous
pursuits means that there's not going to
be rain and it's not gonna be fertile in
the landscape there's going to be close
tie there let's see here now where I got
I've lost my place of course okay
despite featuring the animal so
prominently this painting actually has
surprisingly little to say about pigs
beyond their role as objects of the hunt
paintings wild boar in agricultural
fields that nevertheless ignored the
works pig did and made people do in
those fields certainly remained
imaginable in the early 1700s as a
century progressed with associate
political
evils and environmentalist instability I
argue that pigs became paradoxically
less visible and their impact more
ubiquitous in these may War II
miniatures next painting painting from
1751 I would argue that this one can be
considered something of a transitional
painting it depicts maharana pratap
singh the second he was on the throne
very briefly 1751 1753 and his
companions using swords to slash at wild
boar lured to their hunting box with
tempting piles of golden grain just
barely make it out right there well the
action the boar and the princess
attention are all to the left pigs are
also present on the right those two
flowering mango trees right here they
are encircled by a small hedge of tour
or Indian hedge spurge it's a euphorbia
if anyone's into botany these trees the
produce of which would belong to the
state as all mango trees produce wood
are carefully cultivated and protected
against wildlife and domestic cattle and
of course cattle we know are as capable
as pigs of damaging saplings and their
search for fodder in India they eat a
lot of leaf fodder as well it's not just
grasp this is not a vignette of the
prints protecting his subjects crops but
it may reference the princess
cultivation of his own interest in his
own pleasures these are mango trees
after all nothing's better than a mango
the juxtaposition of pigs on the left
and anti pig works on the right makes it
likely that may war ii connoisseurs
would have felt wild boar throughout
this image I don't think that this one
is amiss is an accident we'll see to her
that plant a little more close up in a
moment there are no wild boar however in
the next painting Shiva and dials 1744
miniature oh there's tour by the way
that spiky green stuff lovely stuff it's
also used in to augment fortifications
which is what it's doing here ok there's
juvenile's painting so this is Shivan
dial 1744 miniature of maharana jagat
singh the second 1734 251 he's
hawking near his capital city of who
depart as in the first painting the
dominant feeling here is heroic courage
the background of romance however is
supplanted I would argue by mirth or
humor up in the corner there we've got a
writer being thrown from his horse and
this is something you're going to laugh
at you're not going to feel sorry for
him this is you know poor horsemanship
this is a comic figure there's a couple
other hints that comedy is the
underlying thing in this image like why
is this painting stresses the
interrelations of kings nobles and
subjects and landscapes while also
reaffirming hierarchies even reifying
those hierarchies and gesturing towards
an idealized may worry prosperity here
it's less generalized and more likely to
map onto a specific named location
particularly looking at that field
bisected by the stream finally as the
party proceeds around the frame this is
another sequential one we recognize
several of the sequential scenes you
have arrival at the hunting grounds
which is their marching up here you have
the pursuit of the prey which is
happening here and concluding here with
the capture of the hawk catch is one of
the crane then they proceed down here
have a feast and then a formal third bar
that's kind of a court thing in our
previous image the 1725 these two scenes
were collapsed then there's this odd
little scene here which seems to be
happening before the scene certainly
where there's a bit of a conference on
this rocky outcropping over Neath over
the field this well wandered field
dominating the center of the painting
for me it certainly it draws the eye
with its swath of negative green space
the ripening grain here is evenly grown
and lush I'm going to zoom in on it for
you there are no blanks in here it's
perfectly full around the field there's
an unbroken hedge of thorny robust tour
the artist mr. spot right there please
ignore that this is precisely in this
you know where this tour is this is
precisely where the wild boar are or
rather aren't in this image living
fences like this helped keep pigs
other wildlife at bay with little cost
up front native tour and naturalized
Berkeley Potter another favorite hedge
plant grew in the wild and propagated
easily but like any other living fence
they required constant maintenance
besides there were a long term
investment most hedge species required
several years of growth before becoming
functional not everyone could afford the
time or labor nor could all reasonably
expect to reap the benefits of something
coming so far in the future certainly
not in the 1700s nevertheless hedges or
mud and stone walls for the better off
were the state's preferred solution far
preferable to letting their peasants go
after their bore and trying to kill them
as maharana fateh singh and he's on the
throne 1884 to nineteen twenty one point
later as he reminded his subjects in
1921 incidentally when his subjects were
going after his pig and really
complaining about them he said near the
city and everywhere there are enclosures
throughout the area of gira there are
also enclosures from the earliest times
the system of enclosure has come down
you too instead of killing my papers
right you too can put up a double treble
good and strong hedge funny hedges Supt
or or walls appear also around village
compounds palace gardens and nobleman's
properties and several other 18th
century paintings but so far as I have
been able to determine fields are only
shown twice more once in eighteen sixty
eight and then again in 1916 so both
those outside are seventeen hundreds
obviously the 1868 painting there you go
five minutes okay the 1868 painting
shows maharana Shambhu Singh he's
eighteen sixty-one 274 touring the
countryside on the occasion of the Maori
New Year during the rainy month of
shravan it depicts three fully hedged
fields one of them does involve to her
the others I'm not sure what this brown
stuff is meant to represent but surely
something nice and dense and thorny so
this field here is the one that also has
tour around the edges you'll have to
trust me when you can see it closer than
you can make out
plant it also shows several figures
seated and raised platforms ready to
drive away any animal that nevertheless
go in here's one of them my hands not
very steady is it there's another and
there's a third so each field has its
own platform the painter is in May
whar's Royal atelier clearly knew that
living fed excuse me hedge not fed
tenses but hedge fences were deterrent
not a fail-safe the perfection of these
fields in their fertility and closure
and their cultivator scope for vigilance
was an idealized portrait of memoir
itself this is certainly not reality
this is what the state would like things
to be pigs it would seem have no place
in this landscape although in paintings
documenting other or appropriate
occasions tiger hunts for example the
animals pigs are shown in some of these
very same hills that we see here and
this is a very specifically realized
painting from the these hills I can tell
you exactly which some of these are
there on the outskirts outskirts of
udaipur here's the city palace which
still stands it's a great place to go
and visit it's gorgeous this is much LA
and tickly Amara's and it has a little
tiny fort up on the top call deck linger
which would probably two or three times
over fit in this room it's ridiculously
tiny this is probably bunky magura and
this one I didn't look it up but I know
from the landscape which one it is so
these are real places this is not
however a perfect representation quote
of objective reality because to get this
to actually fit the landscape of may or
you would have to transpose the image
and then we would be standing in the
middle of the lake instead of out in the
landscape so it's not they're not going
for no perfect objective reality or
prospective anything like that they're
going for recognizability of the scene
and and the feeling is so much more
important than quote accuracy is
the 1916 painting the next one the final
one actually here it is much simpler
it's quite reminiscent actually I would
say of that 1725 one where we started in
the way it's abstracting the Mawari
landscape this shows a maddened elephant
his name was God's nyak this means
elephant hero he's breaching a prickly
pear hedge it's unclear if this hedge
was meant to recall the presence of wild
boar in the landscape or not the
painting is primarily about the elephant
and the alternating sensations or
feelings of wonder horror and heroism
involved in the scenes of its fury and
submission and horrors definitely here
if you didn't notice that fellow's being
gored to death right this hedge like the
prickly pear it is composed of may be
naturalized signifying nothing except
the common ideal appearance of an
unmistakably and absolutely mawari field
the concept of the naturalized I'm
playing around with this I think it
might be useful here first is a
biological phenomenon describing an
introduced plant or animal that has
established itself in the wild in a
place where it's not indigenous at least
initially second as a category of
citizenship describing a foreigner
transformed by governmental powers and
processes into one that belongs and
third as a mental process kind of akin
to reification perhaps I'm describing
something that is not natural but over
time has been taken to be and in some
ways by all most popular consent made
natural by the early 20th century it
seems the work of pigs had been hidden
from sight by being naturalized in plain
view I don't think we're supposed to
look at this and see pigs I think we're
supposed to look at it and see
cultivation and of course dodge nyek
he's the star here the damage that pigs
did or perhaps the peasants growing
ability to perturb the state with their
demands for redress felt foreign I argue
to may war indeed maharana Fateh Singh
refused to believe that his subjects
truly suffered from wild boar he
insisted that in earlier times there
were far more wild boar much more
destruction than there was now and yet
some reason to
to believe that with with some honesty
as a result I would say that the work
these animals cause people to do because
of what I'm suggesting here that's
naturalization I think that that work
became something else entirely something
unconnected to them so just a quick
little concluding paragraph here just as
the prickly pear cactus had long lost
its foreignness the Portuguese most
likely brought it in in the 1500s and
they brought in several different
varieties or at least three or four
different varieties of prickly pear all
over India now quite naturalized so just
as a prickly pear had long lost its
Forness becoming naturalized from the
Deccan and the south through the Punjab
in the north sometime between the early
sixteenth and in the eighteenth
centuries the idealized presence of
prickly pear and truer hedges became
naturalized in these paintings no longer
required or necessarily signifying pig
form a war ii connoisseurs the
naturalized unremarkable Atia of hedges
eventually hid world war from view but
it shouldn't have faced for us their
determinative role in the May warrior
web of relationships and just for fun
because I think I have a minute that's
the best painting it's going to close up
on those pig there you go I think that's
cool so this just this is a very fine
miniature and one question I have about
these miniatures that I need to figure
out is if the painter is actually used
at all boar bristles in any other
paintings I'm so curious to know if they
actually used boar bristles to actually
then make the paintings of pigs that
would be a nice footnote someplace
alright thanks
great fix that so it's been a great
pleasure to be here with so many old and
new friends I want to thank again all
the organizers of the conference in da
over having this has been a really kind
of wonderful weekend and the work I'm
doing today is an extension of the
material that's in my 2011 reaction
animal series book pig and I want to
talk about labor in a slightly different
way I think that probably was intended
by the nature of the description of this
panel on labor Ecology's and think about
some really contemporary issues
surrounding the labor of bacon mania in
American culture in fact i was even
watching sports last night and they're
all these really weird ads about bacon
on television during college football
games so I'll begin with this one of the
things I think most of us here know is
that a pork consumption has long been a
useful lens and to race region in class
you can see or how these parts of the
pig or linked with different racial and
ethnic groups like the British or
african-americans in this case but the
recent bacon mania is much as much as
much cultural as it is culinary and I
think it's worth the attention of animal
studies scholars and activists because
it highlights both our successes and
challenges in changing attitudes about
and practices involving the production
in killing of pigs while a significant
number of animal studies scholars do not
consume bacon although I am very curious
about people's thoughts about vegetarian
and vegan bacon substitutes as well as
the often-cited claim that bacon is
kryptonite or a gateway drug that lures
vegetarians and vegans back into
meat-eating I would like to suggest that
still we're thinking about what bacon
signifies an hour late capitalist social
media driven consumer culture when a
bacon equality sign can be mobilized and
struggles for marriage equality for
example bacon production in consumption
and what I like to call the bacon
culture that largely erases the former
in celebrating the latter serves as a
useful way in to a number of issues in
contemporary American culture including
factory farming animal exploitation and
environmental destruction on the
production side and the implications of
meat-eating structured by race gender
and class on
in public health and our fast food
nation I will not be able to talk about
all of this in the short presentation
today of course but thankfully many of
these issues are familiar to this
audience it's actually really great to
be at a conference room we all know a
lot of the same stuff which is really
kind of wonderful instead I would like
to talk about how bacon has become so
ubiquitous this is the bacon and beer
festival ad from Boston how the
celebration of bacon reflects and
produces ideas about class and gender
and about how this bacon mania
ultimately works to make pigs disappear
behind their end products furthering the
distance between human and non-human
animals in the production of meat an
arena where is a not pick has recently
noted relationship our operate in their
exemplary purity that is operate with
the fewest moral or material obstacles
I'd like to suggest we need to combat
the cultural erasure of the fact that
pigs are bacon bacon is pigs contesting
the culture of meat and the backlash
against vegetarianism and veganism at
the level of consumption as well as
production I particularly like this
image this is the only one I've ever
found where the look of bacon is
transposed onto the outside of the body
of a pig so it's really interesting to
image do so in my history of the complex
human Pig relationship in my book pig in
2011 I wrote about the renewed interest
of pigs in pigs and pork in the American
culinary community in American popular
culture unbeknownst to most however the
celebration of pork in modern America
actually has substantial historical
roots in the 19th century pork
consumption was so prevalent that dr.
john s wilson of columbus georgia wrote
quote the United States of America might
properly be called the great hog eating
Confederacy or the Republic of pork dhum
unquote he noted quote so far as meat is
concerned his fat bacon and pork fat
bacon and pork only and that continually
morning noon and night for all classes
sexes ages and conditions unquote
connections between Americans in pork
between pork and the nation or today's
backlash is more about the individual
were made visible in the porcine a graph
in 1876 map of the United States in the
shape of a pig I love the fact that
Cuba's little sausage there and in an
1884 map that used pigs to illustrate
the nicknames of the state's produced by
HW Hill and company of Decatur Illinois
the United States and a pork ranks third
and per capita consumption behind
chicken and beef in part because of
health concerns about pork but mostly
because of the success of factory
farming and making chicken and beef more
accessible unless
pensive pork was especially demonized in
the 1980s in the industry as we know
responded by turning pork into chicken
rebranding it as the other white meat in
the face to four percent annual declines
in pork consumption interesting of the
industry is now decided that pork is red
meat again they've rebranded pork as you
see here in this image with the names of
cuts of traditional cuts of steak cuts
of beef in this case which is
interesting a pork is rebounded in fact
pork is going to pass beef in late 2016
in terms of per capita consumption the
US pork is rebounded in part because of
the success of the industry and
rebranding its products especially and
it's diligent work to get consumers and
restaurants to include more pork
products especially bacon in meals the
food service industry has helped fuel
the recent bacon crazed by adding the
product to dishes and meals where it had
not been eaten before restaurants use
bacon is an ingredient because of its
high flavor profile in fact according to
David Kessler author of the end of
overeating one standard line in the
restaurant business is quote when in
doubt throw cheese and bacon on it
unquote pork producers are trying to
extend bacon consumption to other day
parts as they call them in both
restaurant and free cooked meals hoping
to expand Americans eating of bacon
beyond breakfast or as a supplemental
ingredient in green beans or as a pizza
topping many disturbing retail
innovations have been important here
especially the development marketing a
precooked bacon perhaps the ultimate
convenience meat and flavored bacon
products today's Renaissance import is
largely as highly gendered in class
National Pork Board research indicates
that men are the predominant purchasers
and consumers of pork and anecdotally
most of the drivers of interest in pork
and restaurants and social media have
been men bacon mania also serves an
index to social class at the high end
numerous websites including bacon of the
Month Club in blogs promote artisanal
varieties of bacon and ham several
restaurants specialize in pig and pork
including Donald links kashan and New
Orleans in several pork-based cookbooks
including Stefan Marino's pork & Sons
and Martin Picard's opioid to cost Shawn
the album drawn from his Montreal
restaurant have become bestsellers
middle and upper-class foodies delight
in procuring and consuming often quite
expensive heirloom and artisanal pork
products including bacon that is slow
cured in traditional ways that are now
marginal to the way most pork is
actually
duced in contrast the bacon put a nice
picture Ossabaw here in contrast the
bacon celebrated as part of bacon mania
is not artisanal but is an industrial
product that can be produced in a modern
port processing plant in a matter of
hours wet curing in vain pumping long
ago we place dry curing of hams and
bacon the standard supermarket bacon
first emerged from the 1920s became a
staple of family breakfasts in fact
bacon is still largely eaten as a
breakfast food the average America will
have bacon 18 times per year just over
two-thirds of that sixty nine percent as
strips at breakfast some have argued
that bacon the appeal of bacon is tied
to its status is a comfort food one many
of us remember from childhood others
have claimed that there's something
unique and compelling about the smell
and taste of bacon and indeed much
research both consumer and scientific
has gone into studying how the salt fats
in umami a loanword from Japanese used
to describe the pleasant savory taste of
some foods of bacon it made it such a
popular food item and flavoring while
not discounting the appeal to many of
the taste of bacon a reminder of the
challenges we face in positioning
ethical concerns against real and
perceived pleasures in fact when the
question is how do we can test the
presumption that deliciousness all too
often Trump's the human animal and
environmental costs of meat it is my
contention that the apparent current
interest in all things bacon related is
more cultural than culinary and serves
in part is a way to rebel against
increasingly health-conscious and
politically correct Society now this is
the party line the numerous articles and
books that Chronicle and fuel bacon
mania a decidedly overdetermined
phenomenon aviva Shen suggests the quote
putting bacon on everything or wearing
it as lingerie a reference to the bacon
bikini memes shown here as a statement
of hedonism pure and simple a defiant
stand against any movement that suggests
we moderate what we eat unquote this is
called my call and Carol Adams image
certainly many of the products in both
the fast-food industry and individual
chefs reflect American gluttony at its
worst Wendy's Baconator so this is not
the baconator six strips of bacon atop a
half pound cheeseburger a
jack-in-the-box is artificially flavored
bacon milkshake and homegrown inventions
such as the bacon explosion that's what
this is bacon explosion is two pounds of
bacon wrapped around
pounds of sausage and grilled are
clearly acclaimed a masculinity a
response to elite an effeminate foodie
snobbery in an assertion of democratic
eating pleasures is Sarah hep Allah
writes in a summary of this bacon mania
from any quote loving bacon is like
shoving a middle finger in the face of
all that is healthy and holy while an
unfiltered cigarette smolders between
your lips unquote the analogy between
smoking eating bacon is an interesting
by the way we could talk about later
perhaps similarly in their recent
recently published book bacon nation
Peter Kaminski and Marie Rama argued
that quote part of the current bacon
craze is due no doubt to a social
phenomenon you could call good nutrition
fatigue bacon obsession has become a way
to proclaim our independence from the
food police who would have us mostly eat
a diet of boiled lentils and mashed
yeast unquote a note here of course how
these bacon advocates use these
ridiculous arguments about what
vegetarians and vegans actually eat no
one I know eats boiled lentils and
mashed yeast in that sense but this
calls attention I think to the politics
of pleasure which has come up a couple
times this week the politics of pleasure
and debates about food in the way that
pleasure erases the exploitation and
killing of non-human animals in
providing those pleasures so most of us
here familiar with the contours of this
actively and corporately supported pro
meat backlash there are many commercials
and images I could have used and here as
part of this process something that I
fact view is an indicator of our
successes proponents of human health
ecological sustainability and animal
liberation this backlash also indexes
the anxiety of consumers about their
meat eating and the fears of those in
and promoting animal agriculture
industries that people might move away
from their horrific products do
surrounding pigs and pork in the past
and present serve as a reminder how
we're all deeply enmeshed with animals
and then when it comes to animals our
contradictory attitudes and practices
are the norm by paying attention to the
power dynamics surrounding questions of
visibility and invisibility however
hopefully we can develop an
understanding of pigs and other aspects
of non human nature that we're making
history with they will prompt us to
think beyond ourselves to include other
species in both our imaginations and our
material existence after all the goal of
animal studies and new approaches to the
presumed division between nature and
culture should be to help us think
differently and more importantly live
differently where the animals with
we co-create our world Thanks okay great
so echoing also all the thanks but also
to say isn't it fun to be at a place
where you're not the weird Pig person
but instead you just another Pig person
among many so because we're so
interdisciplinary just I'll say that I
did my PhD in development sociology and
before that I was an agronomist so that
explains a little bit of my attraction
to things like how marks thought about
soil fertility which is part of what I'm
talking about today um when we think
about pigs today it's difficult not to
discuss China so that's what I'm going
to do talk about my work about pigs in
China and the place to start okay was
with a day the place to start is the
place that I sort of started with this
work and that's in this graph so several
years ago I was studying global
livestock and feed complexes building on
sort of interests and concerns about how
and why it was that we were dedicating
all this land and water and resources to
feed livestock when there were hundreds
of millions of people in the world who
were hungry so here we see these four
different categories of meat production
globally starting when the FAO started
producing this data in 1960 and the
moment for me is this moment in 1979
when pork overtakes beef to become the
most produced meet in the world and it
really captured my imagination and as I
started looking into it it didn't take
long to realize that this was also
really a story that was importantly
about China so in 1978 one year before
this initial uptick was the year that
done chopping announced reforms to open
China's economy so that was D
collectivization and it was the
emergence of private enterprise and it
was selective trade liberalisation and
one result of these changes was that
pork production starts to increase
markedly and this process is further
spurred throughout this time by the
liberalisation
soy imports in China in the early 1990s
and that led to the current situation
where China imports seventy percent of
the global soy trade predominantly to
feed its pigs and so much of my work is
focused on trying to understand how and
why pork is so important in China and to
who and with what implications including
things like ideas of people eating pork
and revenge against scarcity and
rationing in the past and relationships
to the state but in the time I have
today I'm going to give just a kind of a
shorthand version of how I'm thinking
about the causes and consequences of
China's pork boom which are also related
to how I'm trying to think about pork
and meet more broadly so we all know the
concept of nutrition transition which is
this idea that as income increases meat
consumption increases and we can
actually chart this across the world in
a number of different places where
income Rises so too does meat
consumption and the sister concept to
the nutrition transition is the
livestock revolution which is understood
as sort of a production response to
increasing consumer demand for meat so
these are the two concepts that are
typically used at least in sort of
mainstream development understandings
about the relationship of meat and
development the problem is that these
are descriptive concepts that are
treated as prescriptive or even as
aspirational goals where meat is equated
with progress it's equated with
development and and it's understood as
sort of a natural and inevitable result
of modernity and result of development
but these concepts also conceal that
dietary transition is or dietary
transformation is also highly political
and it has distinct beneficiaries who
benefit from increasing meat consumption
and also it has distinct sort of losers
to put it bluntly so in the work that
I've done on China's meat revolution I'm
proposing this is sort of a different
way to think about nutrition transition
that actually puts the politics and the
power who has the power in the
distribution of the benefits and the
harm of the food system really at the
center of the analysis and in particular
I've looked at this
the relationship between increasing meat
consumption and state legitimacy in
China in the reform era which I don't
really have time to talk about here and
except for to say that this industrial
meat regime has been wildly successful
in China throughout the reform era so
today half the world's pork production
half the world's pork consumption and
half of the world's pigs are in China
and much of this is commodity pork
products produced using industrial
methods and just it's important to
quickly note here that per capita meat
consumption in China is still much less
than it is in places like the United
States and Western Europe so as not to
kind of overstate we have to be very
careful about thinking about
inequalities also in a in a global scale
the paper that I submitted for the
conference is trying to explore China's
industrial meet Rosie regime using
Marx's idea of metabolic rift so just
quickly to say what that is about it
turns out that marks actually thought
about ecology and ecological crisis and
he proposed this idea of metabolism
which he borrowed from soil scientists
at the time metabolism was for him that
human labor and human production was the
embodiment of human nature relations so
that humans through our labor and
production we transformed nature and at
the same time ourselves transformed that
humans are part of nature but our
relations to non human nature are
socially mediated through the
organization of Labor or the mode of
production so mark Kames marks came to
this idea trying to understand declining
soil fertility in the 19th century in
Britain and he proposed that the reason
for declining soil fertility had
everything to do with capitalism and
with the enclosures in particular so
people are moving off the land moving
into cities what they take with them is
soil nutrients in the form of their poop
that instead of going back to the soil
instead becomes an urban sewage
management disaster so this is a rift in
this soil nutrient cycle and the second
part of that was how
grain also parallel that movement of
bodies that grain holding soil nutrients
follows people to the city and instead
of the nutrients in the grain going back
to the soil it again goes through human
bodies and into urban sewage systems so
for marks the rift is about these
disruptive disrupted cycles that are
related to the increasing physical and
social distance between food production
and consumption or a town country
division of labor to put it in his words
and today people use the metabolic rift
more broadly to discuss ruptures in
metabolic processes of systems and so
I've been interested in a number of
shifts or riffs or transformations since
1978 in China and both on their own and
how they're related to each other the
first is this profound shift in value
from pigs to commodity pork so as we've
learned pigs were domesticated in China
six to seven thousand years ago and for
millennia were raised as integral parts
of crop livestock systems but their
value came from their manure production
their manure was what fueled grain based
diets and people really ate pork only
once or twice a year today however the
exchange value of commodity pork has
largely displaced this use value of pigs
it's not complete but that's the
direction right the second shift which
is related is about manure and so the
use value of pigs again was derived from
them being fertilizer factories on four
legs as mounted on famously set and and
it was this metabolic relation perhaps
between pigs and the fueling of grain
based diets that was the source of value
today manure from industrial livestock
operations mostly pork but also chicken
is the number one source of water
pollution in China today more than
industry more than factories it's
industry it's it's manure from
industrial livestock operations part and
parcel of this industrial form of
production is the adoption of modern pig
breeds and China's home to something
like 100 indigenous pig breeds with a
variety of locally adapted variety so
that
places have their own kind of pig breeds
today however exotic breeds are
displacing or even replacing those
breeds so a Ministry of Agriculture
official I interviewed said that ninety
to ninety-five percent of China's pork
which is again half of all the pork in
the world is produced from dly pigsty
rockland race and yorkshire pigs and so
this again is another profound shift and
the combination of exotic breeds and
industrial feeding is also a
transformation of the pork itself
several people I interviewed in China
complain that pork today has no flavor
and these were people who remember life
sort of before the livestock revolution
or the industrial meat regime and when
indigenous pigs were raised on scrap
yeah thank you and produced a kind of
fat that had was layered fat so culinary
traditions are based on this kind of fat
both the flavor and its consistency but
as soy and maize based commercial feeds
have come to dominate and DIY pigs and
short production cycles and market
standards that value in term us cooler
fat rather than back fat and
supermarkets today are flooded with
leaner meat that's also sold as the
healthier variety so often times you
will also hear young people voice their
preference for lean meat which suggests
the manufacturer of consumer demand the
way that these things can manufactured
and finally the making of modern meat is
conditioned by changing forms of labour
so there's increasingly quite a lot of
studies coming out especially from
Chinese scholars who are looking at the
agrarian question in China trying to
understand the extent to which peasants
might be becoming workers what kinds of
particular conditions there are in China
that that condition these relationships
and of course they're very complex so to
simplify it grossly to say in the pork
sector we see a rapid decline of
smallholder farmers in 2008 alone half
of the households in China that produced
pigs stopped producing pigs in one
and along with this is a rapid increase
in waged Labour's and contract farmers
and these transformations aren't whole
they are complete the wage labour is
often subsidizing in ways the
smallholder farmers by family sending
remittances back to the countryside so
the two work together but what is clear
is that this small scale of production
is declining so this just shows the
share of production of three different
kind of scales of production that
analysts are fond of using these are the
same three scales that the rabobank
shows to predict changes into the future
where you see the larger scale
production taking more and more share
and rather than just thinking of these
three types as sort of scales I think of
them more as ideal typical
representations of something like human
hog labour ecologies which is your
fantastic concept that I like very much
I so just very quickly to go through
these three kind of different types and
the type that's emerging perhaps most
dramatically our commercial operations
which we all know about these are K foes
these are large-scale industrial factory
farms these are farms that raise tens or
hundreds of thousands of pigs per year
and I think the key thing to understand
about commercial farms in China about K
foes in China is that they allow the
country to get around this high
population limited land conundrum
there's an oft-cited statistic that
China has twenty one percent of the
world's population and only nine percent
of its arable land so in order to feed
the whole population and at the same
time to bring about these massive
increases in meat consumption k foes
that operated on imported feed stuffs
are really the only option if that's the
goal that really is the only option I'm
not supporting that goal I'm just saying
it's the only way to do it so Capo's of
course take a little amount of land and
produce an awful lot of meat and do so
in a way that doesn't compete directly
with food production it does compete in
directly which I'll return to one more
key that is somewhat unique in
is that the expansion of commercial
operations is led by firms called dragon
head enterprises which are agribusiness
firms that are state supported and
they're typically processors so China's
largest pork processor is Shuang way or
shine way which the name you likely
recognized as the firm about Smithfield
Foods in 2013 the second type then and
one that is increasing the most is this
mid scale of production called
specialized household farms and these
farms supply the industrial processors
so they may be individual farmers who
have scaled up they may be farmers
who've come together in order to focus
more particularly on pig production and
some of them produce on contract with
commercial farms some of them sell to
and to integrators that then sell and
which are the animals this is a highly
subsidized form of production mostly
through pig barns and an analyst
estimate that more than that sixty
percent of the country's total slaughter
today is from farms that raise 50 or
more pigs that still seems some ways
like a small scale but it's actually
quite different and the the direction is
moving ever larger and then finally we
have the backyard farmers who raise less
than 10 pigs a year they grow crops
another livestock on about a half acre
of land they raise indigenous exotic
hybrid pigs which are valued as much for
their manure as for their meat these
farmers don't typically purchase feed
they don't produce under contract and
they don't make much money from their
pigs or they lose money for their pigs
and farm income here is generally
supplemented again by remittances from
migrant workers in the family so again
this swine sector restructuring along
these three kind of ideal typical types
has been incredibly successful in terms
of dramatically increasing pork
production and consumption but it's also
characterized by a number of failures or
crises which bring us back then to the
metabolic rift the first metabolic rift
is about feeding China's pigs which I'll
just say is also the title of a
or that I wrote a few years ago for the
institute of agriculture and trade
policy and it has a lot of this I mean
it's written as a report so it's more
informational so if these things are
something you want some statistics about
it might be a good place to look for
them so again it's k foes that operate
on imported feed as the only way to ramp
up pork consumption in a place that has
the land mass about the size of the
United States but a population of 1.3
billion and the shift to commercial
feeding of China's pigs is only possible
again by harvesting soy and maze from
mana crop fields in North and South
America and I think we're all familiar
with the ecological and climate
implications of industrial crop
production end of the long distance
grain trade so I won't really discuss
that here but the point is that the
scale of these feet imports again
seventy percent of global soy trade is
expressed in a global scale metabolic
rift so we see declining soil fertility
in the global locations where farmers
grow crops to feed China's pigs coupled
with excess nutrients inside China where
those pigs are eating and defecating in
the millions of tons of soy in maize
that are being pumped through k fo pigs
create millions of tons of this modern
lean pork and billions of tons of manure
and so the second drift here is in the
manure itself and again this changing
value this change from manures value to
manure is waste and when the pig becomes
a commodity it's high as value comes in
the form of the pork it produces as
articulated in price the firm's that
control its production distribution and
sale benefit most directly from this
form of value while the smaller holder
farmers prices perhaps their biggest
problem if they try to sell their pigs
the prices they receive are barely worth
the effort so replacing the manure value
of pigs with the price value of pork
ruptures agricola gical cycles and
manure shifts from being a valuable
resource to a toxic waste and again the
dangerous conditions in China's
waterways as this photo shows is the
clearest evidence of this rift and the
industrial meet regime not only wastes
manure by transforming it from a
resource to an excess it also i would
argue way
the rural by channeling by challenging
real social reproduction so already in
China 300 million people are without
access to safe water and already
one-fifth of China's waters classified
as toxic two-fifths is seriously
polluted and more than half of all the
country's water is considered poor to
very poor so putting this in a justice
and an equity frame it's important to
consider who's eating industrial meat
and who is suffering from its crises so
in the aggregate urban people in China
eat two to three times more meat than
people in rural areas and this is a
figure that mirrors broader social
stratification in the country where
income is also three times higher in
urban areas than rural areas and going a
bit finer grain if you look just at the
meat consumption of middle and upper
class urban households it's three to
four times higher than rural residents
so there's clear class differences in
meat consumption which I've elsewhere
called meat for the elite at the same
time that we have meat for the lead we
have rural bodies of water role bodies
of land and rural bodies of people that
bear the brunt of industrial meats
burden this is especially true of
smallholder farmers who rely on heavily
polluted water for their household and
agricultural use and this is to say that
underlying the elite who are eating high
on the hog if we like our rural people
in spaces who may not be eating much at
all or who have their ability to produce
for self-consumption or market
consumption quite challenged by some of
these socio-environmental crises yeah in
addition to these rifts and nutrient
cycles there's also what we might call
an epistemic rift that is a rift in ways
of knowing farming as farmers become
workers we have to think about what
happens to agricultural knowledge of
knowing meat as meat becomes more symbol
of progress end of knowing nature as
consumers are confronted with this
anonymous food in the market and as
farms operate in ways that are precisely
about overcoming non-human limits or
non-human human non-human relationships
so my way of conclusion let me say that
industrial livestock production and
increasing meat consumption can't go on
forever and that these riffs are less
stages or moments and more processes and
direction
which means that they can change it's
not easy but they can so I'm ending here
on this more positive note of a farmer
in Sichuan named mr. Huang who in this
picture is cooking lunch it's vegetables
but he's using fuel from his biogas
digester he has about eight pigs but
they produce enough to provide cooking
fuel and keep the lights on throughout
the year and and there's a there's a lot
I could say about mr. Huang he's quite
an inspiring guy but I'm thinking of him
here at the end of talking about the
crises of industrial meat production
because of the way he tries to operate
in something like a value unity of
manure and pigs which this idea of value
unity perhaps moves us in the opposite
direction of a metabolic rift thanks
spotlight I hi I'm Julie thank you very
much for your presentation it was very
interesting i actually wanted to i don't
i don't necessarily have a question but
i wanted to draw attention to what i
think is a very interesting connection
between wild boar and may war and
domestic case in new york city has
described by effort i believe um the
other day um they are actually two sides
of the same coin and the coin is the
prosperity well being able to pour you
know so for a wiring Prince's wild boar
equal pleasure and conquest in your for
the New York City wealthy domestic pigs
he will discuss I'm form a wiring
peasants wild whoracle destruction for
the New York City for domestic day
people production and in May war the
boar inspector their effects are hidden
from view in a New York City the
domestic pigs especially in effects are
highlighted and brought into sharp focus
and you know finally in each case the
wealthy relate to pigs according to
their own interests and act on that
relation at the expense of the interest
of the pool and I think it's really just
pretty wild amazing that you have sort
of the exact same well that makes me you
have the same dynamic on opposite sides
of the world in relation to pigs in
particular
answer now Oh collect questions okay I
actually had a specific question for me
but others can weigh on it they like um
the FAO statistics on China's patterns
of consumption and soy consumption
especially over the last 30 years um how
much do you trust those statistics to
what degree do you think they were found
reality to what degree do you think the
last 30 years of statistical evidence on
patterns of pork production are being
used to forecast the next 30 years in
China and maybe more importantly to what
degree do you think that statistical
description of nutrition transition is
being used forecasts nutrition
transitions elsewhere in the world where
the relationship between people and
biggest may play out something
differently
yeah sure I'll just say something about
that quickly way um well I don't know
how much to trust fao statistics are not
right but that they suggest trends I
don't know that I would bet my life on
them being exactly right but in terms of
production statistics now being used to
predict this future growth and also this
idea of the nutrition transition I think
it's really wrapped up in this normative
idea of meat being progress and
assumptions that this can just go on
forever right I mean that's what the
rabobank and their their predictions 2
2015 is just ever increasing growth and
then there's some sort of faith in sort
of science and technology that will that
will cure these problems that you know
if we just internalize the externalities
or something all of this language that
really just betray is kind of a faith
that I think doesn't doesn't it really
allow us to look at these problems which
I think excuse me our problems about
environmental justice and social justice
that I mean the nutrition transition and
production figures precisely don't want
to engage with because it messes up all
the models I just want to comment that's
comment form ndi I commend you on your
presentation today you know where things
are at present you know with pork
production and I think it you know it
really overviews with the note agreeing
usage and everything that goes chef's
China now with China purchasing
Smithfield you know it is
it's quite a thing we all need to
realize that you know they're shifting
their waste management and all of us to
the US and you know it's a pretty wise
decision by China to only operations
here the feeds here the waste is left
here with their contaminated stream so
you know I appreciate you opening this
up you know so that you know we have a
broader idea of where we are presently
with the pork production have a brief
observation that an open query the
observation is that historically no
western city ever reproduced its
population from its in from demographic
growth until about the mid 19th century
or so but that was never true for China
China's cities grew from a population
book from within the city because
systematically historically the night
soil was ruled it was a huge business to
get the win the option for the night
soil to take it to the fields outside so
to tune in that case in a sense the
waist was recycled to fertilize the
fields and not sort of left in urban
sewage systems or in water horses the
other question I guess I invite you all
to talk about is this question of diet
and class a long time ago had a
gentleman Louis inside was the world's
expert on the democratization of media
europe since most ordinary people in ref
didn't eat maybe once a month once every
week and the authorization of a meeting
was an extraordinary thing and i'm with
respect to the pig the in medieval
banquets i'm told in the West the
aristocracy a big wild things like stags
and so on the next lowest table 8 wild
things that were smaller like pheasants
and so on and the lowest table 8
barnyard animals so there was the bigger
and the wilder it was the higher status
it was to eat and it's interesting to
figure out where the pink belongs in
this stratification and I think it kind
of varies from culture to culture it's a
kind of liminal I think in this respect
because it's a kind of a household
it's liminal e unlike the sky it's a
quasi household animal or potentially
household animal and the I remember the
look fine shed the decay which recounts
the revolution in a Chinese village and
one of the scenes that I'll never forget
at the beginning is it is this is just
before the village has its own
revolution and it's chinese new year and
business are walking by the landlord's
house and they smell pork dumplings and
they of course can never eat pork
dumplings and in the revolution in the
beginning they invade the house would
push the landlord and his family aside
and eat all the pork dumplings and it's
one of these sort of world turned upside
down light in the French Revolution
invading bourgeois restaurants are both
a matzo week and you would take over
their plates right with that and finish
their meals for them so this question
somehow a class and meat eating and the
aspiration it's not just that it tastes
good it's that consuming it places you
as a kind of human being able to
celebrate the great cultural rituals of
your civilization wait around anything
well I'll just say something very
quickly which i think is something
that's quite fascinating in China we're
here in the United States kind of the
more yepi meet if you will or these
heritage breeds right and something very
local in China people are doing research
to ask the middle and upper urban
classes about their meat consumption and
overwhelmingly they prefer factory
farmed pork and I think that's because
of great efforts gone to argue that this
is the safest form of pork because it's
easier to regulate and with all the food
safety scandals even though these are
the farms that are precisely responsible
for the food safety scandals they've
been incredibly successful is selling
this idea that modern pork is what
middle number class consumers want
because it's safer because it's more
easy to regulate because it's also
modern so it's this inverse relationship
in some ways with class yeah and if you
if you hang around a bunch of rajputs
today in India or at least the ones I
was interacting with I'm one of the kind
of undertones that you you keep hearing
in terms of diet is a longing for wild
boar meat for teeth or witches you know
pheasant and occasionally also you'll
hear black bra black buck which is an
antelope brought up and some of these
animals can be found on the market and
occasionally you know somebody it's even
offered me some you know poached well
for me when I was doing my research so
this is still very much something that
is desired and I think that your point
that you know an association with the
wild is it's very much part of a factor
for these for these individuals and
there's then a huge difference between
like I've never in all these paintings
that I can find a pig I can never find a
domestic Pig but there were domestic Pig
kept and there was the state was very
interested as well in keeping those pigs
separate from the wild boar because the
wild boar were very close in to the
capital city and they fed them actually
so here we're on that you know where is
domestic where his wild spectrum yet
again they were feeding them nightly and
very close by there were you know
domestic boar
in another paper I think we need a
competition for who has the best phrase
involving porcine in a previous paper i
use porcine miscegenation which i
thought was pretty good would you have
you had the wild boar in the domestic
bored doing as they will and these
concerns are are wild boar still what
they were because a rajput he can only
eat the wild boar he's not going to eat
this dirty animal that is for the very
very low caste so in india also
sometimes not eating meat at all is
going to be a signal of being quite
quite high caste now our raj puts their
high caste but they are very much a
meat-eating high caste so they're kind
of an oddity on that front hub but
should we have I would like to actually
respond but I i can stop to now and do
it later go ahead ok great on the kind
of the parallels with the pigs in New
York it's a definite definitely good
point and I suspect if we we ask
Katherine she would probably say well
there's others characters involved to
other people who are caught up in this
conundrum and certainly that's the case
in India because what i was talking
about of course are these relatively
poor peasants but you also have this
group called the Beales who are more
they often are called tribal they tend
to live more in the forest do a mixture
of small agriculture and some hunter
gathering type things and they have
really interesting close bonds with the
state in terms of providing service and
some ritual functions and things like
that but they're hunters as well so for
them they definitely wanted the boar
around and their source of conflict with
this with the state was that the state
didn't necessarily want them killing the
boar and up to certain times they didn't
approve of the way the board were being
killed as the Beales are not necessarily
acting in accordance with a kind of
sportsmanship that the rajputs kind of
workout in association with the British
as to what the proper way to go after a
pig is and sometimes you know you're
using yeah you're drugging a law do
which is sort of a sweet and you put
that out there for the animals and so
they gets nice opium you get them nicely
addicted and everything and then is that
appropriate or not it depends on who you
are and what the purpose
we just add real quickly in the context
of I think Jim's really great
observation about that is that I'm you
know the relationship of foods to
identity is fascinating and I think one
of things that's interesting about his
store Assize and say the human pig
relationship in the United States is the
long history of that I mean that the
animal is really tied to questions of
kind of a broader sense of national or
regional identity and I think the
interesting shift for me as we've moved
from a producer's Republic to a
consumers Republic is how much now it's
focused on individuals I mean it becomes
kind of an individual assertion as
opposed to thinking about a larger kind
of collective or communal pattern and
that's something I find very intriguing
about kind of American food ways when I
find intriguing is I don't think i've
ever seen bacon in india I don't think
they've got that they do okay I haven't
seen it I've been not looking for it Oh
Brad my questions for you although I
welcome to put it from anyone so I'm
struck by what seems to be the sort of
heteronormative masculinity of the bacon
fat may be exemplified by that image of
like the seemingly hetero couple with
the pig noses in the bacon lube slide
and some wondering is there uh is there
a queer bacon fat at all no are in that
like an express really heteronormative
masculinity that's being performed I
think it's really heteronormative but I
was intrigued by the idea that the you
know that did these marriage equality
bacon sticker started popping up in
California in the last year and I was
kind of like what and popping up on
people's facebook pages so I'm sure it's
out there and I think if I just if I dig
far enough i will find more of that but
there's very much i think this sense i
think we know this i mentioned carols
were Carol Adams as work there's a large
sense I think of the role of this and
playing you know kind of a
heteronormative kind of backlash piece
I'm when I think of that great you know
cheesy TV commercial were you'll men
basically grab a minivan and throw it
into the los angeles river then stomp
off to eat like at carls jr hamburger so
it was very much this kind of sense of
the kind of creating that so it may be
out there and if you know kind of we can
queer bacon in some ways i'd love to
know how to do it yeah where that is and
maybe Gabe knows it there's a there's a
pigs that you men out of read by career
Paris by the name of Tim Dean but it's
human bigs called unlimited intimacy and
I'll leave it at that you're welcome to
investigate the way is winter included
career-making precisely that analytic um
okay so one of the things I was struck
by here is that thinking back through
the entirety of the weekend so far um
the moment of a post visceral revulsion
that I've actually felt personally is in
our kind of series of gasoline bacon
products are many of which contain oh no
bacon like like I found the the big move
in bacon condoms Lloyd more viscerally
but I wanted to look away than anything
else we've seen no and then probably
assessing me like I'm struck by
something that I think Alex said to me
the other day maybe taking from from
temporada which is that the worst vegans
are the ethical ones and best ones are
like once driven by revulsion and I
wonder if we could we could think about
that for a little bit like precisely
because we're also seeing a lot of like
images of suffering I'm proud and I
suppose for cycling back items in my
mind I'm cycling back to some pinch
writings on the politics of the
visibility of violence what what does it
say that that's the moment of revulsion
and that its promotion in some sense is
about a kind of performative masculinity
that is in fact kind of solder to like
incredible like artifice an artist
and then repugnant access why is it why
is it that's what gets me and that the
actual suffering of animals at this
point I'm someone sort of come to
because we have much more striking
images of like animal summary of actual
animal suffering Mindy's presentation
and to know how did Tony animal
suffering like you I should water
suffering okay thanks Marty can you can
anyone anyone walk through this process
with me about why how did the actual
sentiment reserve like propulsion me
maybe a politics of repulsion as well as
a society the only thing that media
comes to mind is yo Benny means
discussion of luck disgusts having to
die to the touch and it may be some
interesting things about that I'm and
I'm I guess I'm less involved in that
with this project than thinking about
the kind of the flip dynamic is that
dynamic a pleasure because there is this
kind of trope that the pleasure and the
flavor of bacon is like it gives you a
cart blush to kind of override kinds of
other types of aspects there and so I
don't know I mean I think it's something
that's like supposed to think through it
I mean I very one of the projects I'm
working on is about the history of
artificial flavoring and I think it's
kind of fascinating that how long we've
had the ability to do these types of
things and how that works and there's
something again about you mention you
like you know things being out of place
you know you know dirt is matter out of
place there's something about that
displacement I think of that animal that
somehow is registering with us when it's
been moved into a completely you know
non natural realm you know either with
the flavorings or with the condoms or
the t-shirts or whatever but I don't
know we need to think that through I
think there's a good set of issues there
I mean for me I had a similar reaction I
mean that that was some of those were
the most i wanted to look away from and
when I was asking myself actually
earlier same question that you're now
asking why I was actually wondering if
some of it actually has to do with with
class and making judgments about that
that that stuff struck me as being in
very poor taste as being kind of low
class or something like that and that's
not maybe the prettiest reaction I was
having but I I
wonder if that's part of it or caught up
in the kitchen asst of it that it's and
also within that nobody called it out
but there is of course the very bad pun
somebody yesterday called out that the
word you know pork and so there was a
very bad pun in that image that some of
us may have been also reacting to I
always think in terms of pun so that's
part of the reason I was kind of
groaning internally back to farmers uh
well a lot of different things happen
sometimes it's just dumped into
waterways just dumped that picture i
took outside of a large-scale breeding
operation and I mean you just see these
rivers all over in real taarna because
there's big industrial farms all over so
sometimes manure is just dumped into
waterways sometimes there are massive
scale bio digesters that are a
possibility I mean there are people
working on handling this problem all the
time and there's quite a lot of focus on
better regulating the industry just this
year a new environmental law came on
that really put came into effect that
really put industrial livestock
production at the center of regulation
trying to improve regulation but I mean
there's we're talking about billions and
billions of tons of manure there's a
point at which is just too much that
even if you have biogas digesters and
commercial owners would tell me that
they had all these different systems in
place of drying it out and spreading it
and sharing it with farms around and
still there was so much waste urine and
manure that just gets dumped in the
water so i would say that a number of
things are happening with it but i would
say the only way to solve it is to stop
producing so much damn pork
up here but we can continue in the break
thank you very much